[Musica]
l'argomento di questa ted di questa
conferenza è il mediterraneo più
precisamente le relazioni fra stati e
popoli all'interno del mediterraneo però
partiamo dalla sardegna che il luogo
dove è maturata l'idea che vorrei
illustrarvi la sardegna come sappiamo
tutti è un'isola è molto noto questo
molto meno noto è che questa condizione
geografica insulare ha portato spesso
nel corso dei secoli i sardi che abitano
l'isola della sardegna ad un isolamento
ad un isolamento culturale al chiudersi
in se stessi che diventa un chiudersi
all'interno della propria comunità e
quando ci si incomincia a chiudere a
rinchiudere non si sa quando si finisce
per esempio la comunità cessa di essere
la sardegna incomincia a essere meno per
esempio può essere il capo di sopra o il
capo 18 può essere la propria città il
proprio quartiere il proprio villaggio
il proprio minuscolo partito politico
la propria corporazione
ecco quando succede questo diventa la
chiusura diventa un limite culturale
drammatico e produce una rovinosa
attitudine culturale a non comprendere
gli altri
anzi a non interessarsi degli altri e
quando questo atteggiamento investe la
classe dirigente e la investe e la
investì anzi subito prima forse degli
altri
ci troviamo di fronte ci siamo trovati
di fronte nei secoli più volte ad una
rovinosa incapacità di governare ma
anche prima che governare di vedere e
comprendere i fenomeni che investono la
sardegna investono quest'isola un grande
sardo che
molto conosciuto anche fuori dai nostri
confini
emilio lussu che è stato un eroe della
prima guerra mondiale un antifascista
inossidabile un il fondatore del partito
sardo d'azione esortava i sardi con
parole che sono un po un po da dirigente
politico e un po da poeta e lui diceva
noi sardi dobbiamo infrangere il
maledetto incantesimo dell'isolamento
che ci avvolge e ci lega con catene
invisibili
queste le sue parole immaginifiche da
cui però si trae la conseguenza che
l'isolamento non è la conseguenza di una
immodificabile situazione geografica ma
è una un incantesimo da infrangere
questo incantesimo da infrangere è
l'obiettivo di molti sardi
fortunatamente e io sono qui a
raccontarvi un tentativo di infrangere
quel quell'incantesimo un tentativo
modesto piccolo intendiamoci ma che ha
un'ambizione grande che è quella di
indicare una strada indicare una strada
e sabbia la classe dirigente sarda e ad
altri a coloro che ci vorranno ascoltare
che vogliono prendere in considerazione
le cose le cose che diciamo
alcuni anni fa ecco la vicenda
la fondazione di sardegna ha deciso una
cosa molto importante nella sua vicenda
ha deciso di istituire una borsa di
studio per cento studenti che possano
rimanere a studiare tre anni per un
triennio tutto il corso universitario
nelle università di cagliari o di
sassari e questi 100 ragazzi devono
provenire dalla tunisia dall'algeria o
dal marocco cioè dai paesi del mondo
arabo che stanno di fronte che stanno di
fronte alla sardegna
il primo obiettivo è stato quello
dichiarato di potenziare
l'internazionalizzazione delle
università sarde cioè del fatto che
dentro le università sarde ci siano non
italiani e non sardi per confrontarsi e
questo e questo e un obiettivo molto
importante
devo anche subito aggiungere che
l'internazionalizzazione di tutte le
università italiane è abbastanza modesto
non è paragonabile con le grandi
università europee
eppure tenete presente che l'istituto
universitario è nato in italia
il secondo obiettivo forse più
importante è a mio parere è senz'altro
più importante è quello di creare una
leva di giovani tunisini algerini
marocchini e sardi e italiani quelli che
studiano con l'oro che diventano amici
una leva di giovani capaci di avere
un'attitudine a studiare fare ricerca
scientifica vivere fare amicizie e
relazionarsi con persone di culture
diverse con approcci mentali diversi di
tradizioni diverse
spinti però dallo stesso obiettivo di
conoscere ed è per migliorare la propria
condizione è la condizione di dei propri
paesi
i primi ragazzi sono arrivati tre anni
fa i primi beneficiari di questa borsa
poco più di tre anni fa hanno superato
difficoltà burocratiche notevoli che non
sarebbe stato possibile superare senza
il contributo prezioso di
un'associazione che voglio ricordare che
si chiama un im ed è un'associazione
volontaria di università raccoglie 100
università del mediterraneo unimed
università del mediterraneo e senza la
collaborazione delle università sarde
sono arrivati e oggi possiamo dire
perché sono passati tre anni tre anni e
mezzo che il bilancio è molto positivo
i ragazzi si sono rivelati studenti
esemplari studenti esemplari hanno
superato gli esami con voti buoni e
molti con voti ottimi con voti
ottime e si sono infine laureati voglio
dirvi di un particolare che mi aveva
molto colpito organizzando queste borse
di studio noi avevamo una preoccupazione
la preoccupazione era che siccome si
trattava di far vedere dei ragazzi di 18
anni 18 anni le famiglie opponessero
qualche resistenza a mandare delle
ragazze troppo giovani
un salto culturale così profondo e
quindi ci eravamo ripromessi avevamo
detto sì vabbè superiamo le difficoltà
almeno il 20 per cento devono essere
ragazze
dobbiamo stabilirli mai cautela fu più
inutile perché le ragazze sono state il
53 per cento cioè sono state un pochino
più dei loro colleghi maschi e si sono
laureate brillantemente esattamente come
come gli altri ma nel corso di questi
anni questi ragazzi che adesso sono
laureati hanno mantenuto vivo ma molto
vivo il rapporto con le loro tradizioni
non solo con le loro famiglie con i loro
amici con le loro amicizie le loro
tradizioni le loro tradizioni anche
religiose del luogo da cui vengono ma
nello stesso tempo si è creato un
rapporto solidissimo con la sardegna
cosa vuol dire la sardegna con i loro
colleghi sardi con i loro amici i loro
ragazzi
per molte ragazze hanno trovato un
fidanzato un un amico che diciamo
la cui presenza segna la loro vita
ancora con i loro docenti e con tutti
coloro che hanno incontrato un episodio
in particolare lo voglio segnalare per
le prime lauree di questi ragazzi
le prime lauree sono state di due
ragazze di due ragazze ed un ragazzo a
sassari e di quattro ragazzi di quattro
di cui una ragazza a cagliari si è fatta
una cerimonia una cerimonia accademica
con tutti i crismi rettori e professori
con la toga il tocco
come sanno fare all'università erano
presenti i rettori di rabat e di tunisi
erano presenti diversi professori e
rappresenta la vice rettore donna
dell'università di algeri
ed erano presenti i genitori amici dei
laureandi come avviene sempre in queste
circostanze una festa insomma io devo
dire ero presente
devo dire che il rettore di cagliari e
di sassari la professoressa da un po il
professor carpinelli hanno pronunciato
dei discorsi non di circostanza
autenticamente commossi posso dirlo
commossi e ispirati a grande affetto e
grande augurio per il futuro
per questi ragazzi che si sono formati
nella nostra terra
venendo da lontano i pochi giorni dopo
le prime lauree il consiglio di
amministrazione della fondazione di
sardegna ha deliberato la conferma del
progetto quello era un progetto
triennale
l'ha confermato per i successivi tre
anni e ha manifestato un intendimento
lodevolissimo a mio parere di rendere
questo progetto permanente un'attività
permanente non era una cosa scontata
tenete presente che questo il progetto
più costoso fra tutti quelli sostenuti
dalla fondazione di sardegna in sardegna
oggi ecco qualcosa di nuovo di cui
voglio parlarvi un'associazione che si
chiama a cus che è un associazione di
fondazioni e di associazioni culturali
che ha la sua base l'idea della
cooperazione fra associazioni culturali
ha proposto un'iniziativa di formazione
per approfondire il rapporto di questi
dei nuovi ragazzi che sono arrivati con
i nostri colpi con la nostra realtà il
tema quale si è proposto il tema è la
democrazia la politica democratica
ora intendiamoci lo dico perché in
questi tempi si fa un po di confusione
non il liberalismo ecco e stiamo
parlando della democrazia con la sua
carica dirompente nel senso della
eguaglianza della parità che un
obiettivo a cui tendere che forse non si
raggiunge pienamente integralmente mai
come la libertà ma cui bisogna attendere
soggettivamente con passione e decisione
questo li vogliamo proporre e ci
rivolgiamo agli studenti quindi più che
come studenti come cittadini ed anche
consentitemi di dirlo perché li vedo con
chi stiamo parlando gente di valore come
potenziale classe dirigente mediterranea
del futuro ma di un futuro prossimo
gli studenti tunisini algerini
marocchini e sardi più chiunque vorrà
unirsi a noi dovranno essere impegnati
in questa attività formativa
l'iniziativa dovrà avere un carattere
triennale e l'obiettivo è come per
l'altro progetto quello di farla
diventare un'istituzione culturale
permanente che abbia sede nella nostra
isola
si va completando il partenariato per
gestire questa attività formativa a
questa scuola
ve ne voglio parlare brevemente perché è
importante innanzitutto perché dà il
senso dell'ampiezza dell'interesse che
questa iniziativa può aver suscitato
innanzitutto la fondazione di sardegna
ha espresso grande interesse dicendo che
vedeva questo come uno sviluppo di un
suo progetto quello delle borse di
studio poi ha aderito al partenariato ad
essere parte di questo progetto alla
fondazione unipolis che ha come scopo la
promozione dei valori della cooperazione
è stato facile intendersi lì perché noi
riteniamo la cooperazione un il più
importante esperimento di democrazia
economica realizzatosi nella storia e
quindi lo avremmo già da soli posti al
posto al centro di questa attività
formale e abbiamo la fondazione unipolis
poi aderito la comunità di sant'egidio
di cui si parla molto
noi siamo molto affascinati dalle due p
che sono alla base del loro programma
loro di co2 p che sono pace e poveri
e allora ci intendiamo facilmente i
poveri per far cessare che siano poveri
la pace come il terreno di sviluppo
dell'umanità e hanno una grandissima
esperienza e sono sono associati a noi
anche formalmente poi è seguita la
società dante alighieri che ha sede in
in tutte le ambasciate all'estero
italiane l'associazione reset il cui
presidente del comitato scientifico e il
professor giuliano amato
diciamo di grande rilievo questa
associazione per la promozione dei
valori di solidarietà è l'associazione
unimed di cui ho detto prima
da ultimo negli ultimissimi giorni sta e
giunta l'adesione l'interesse della
fondazione italianieuropei che anzi già
ospitato nelle pagine della sua rivista
questa iniziativa questa iniziativa gode
del sostegno pieno delle università
sarde che si è manifestato dei giorni
scorsi e del mondo della scuola sardo
rappresentato da molti docenti che
intendono partecipare a questa attività
formativa anche ottenendone il titolo di
credito di formazione professionale mi
sono soffermato sui dettagli mi
scuserete e vado a concludere perché mi
sembravano utili a illustrare il
nocciolo di questa esperienza
questa esperienza intendo le borse di
studio e l'esperienza formativa che
intendiamo cui intendiamo dar luogo ora
è il nocciolo è questo che le relazioni
mediterranee sono così le relazioni
all'interno del mediterraneo sono così
affrontate mi sembra non frequentemente
non solo come accoglienza e solidarietà
con coloro che subiscono guerre
persecuzioni fame la solidarietà e
l'accoglienza è doverosa ma questa
iniziativa mi sembra di più perché mi
sembra che si collochi come un convinto
impegno
nell'interesse comune di popoli diversi
eppure così prossimi geograficamente e
così legati dalla storia che possono
crescere solo intensificando e
migliorando la loro relazione
questo è il nostro obiettivo è molto
grande e mi rendo conto
e l'iniziativa è molto piccola ma
l'obiettivo e questo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]